five-year-old boy is dead and according
to metro police
his babysitter is the one who killed him
it's a story the i-team has been looking
into
vanessa murphy is live just outside the
clark county detention center with more
on that story tonight vanessa
denise sources tell me the suspect's
name is lauren
courtney the 22 year old is here at the
clark county detention center
according to jail records she's facing
charges for first degree murder and
eight counts of child abuse now this
is the child she's accused of killing
five-year-old ryan james peralta his
father says the family does not wish to
speak right now but he sent
this video and these photos of his son
here's what happened according to clark
county's department of family services
on march 11 the babysitter contacted the
parents
to say the child was in physical
distress the parents
rushed home the child was rushed to the
hospital
where he was declared unresponsive the
babysitter was taken into custody
the child died the next day and now
again courtney is facing a murder charge
according to the clark county coroner
this is a homicide
and the child had blunt force injuries
to his head
chest and abdomen there's a gofundme for
ryan peralto's family with the following
words
ryan was a young bright light and
touched so many people's hearts
he was taken from this world much too
soon his loss has devastated his family
and all those around him
we have a link at eight newsnow dot com
now courtney's
next court date is set for may 18. i
requested an interview with her
but she declined we also have a request
in
for her mugshot and arrest report
reporting live downtown vanessa murphy
8 news now